En este video solo voy a multiplicar un montón de polinomios y espero que eso les de
muchísima confianza, y se sientan seguros a la hora de ustedes resolver cualquier problema de
multiplicación de polígonos. Así que digamos que quiero multiplicar 2x por
4x menos 5 así que simplemente, utilizaremos
directamente la propiedad distributiva distributiva perdón, y todo lo que haremos es
utilizar esta propiedad repetitivamente cuando estamos multiplicando
polinomios. Por ejemplo aquí tendríamos que esto es 2x por 4x
¿Ok? más 2x por -5 pero podría decir también que es -5
por 2x ¿Verdad? Simplemente lo que hice en este paso fue hacer la propia
distributiva y multiplico 2x por 4x y luego 2x por -5, ahora 2x por 4x simplemente
puedo re arreglar
los términos y esto es 2 por 4 por "x" por "x" ¿Verdad?
Ahora 2 por 4 es 8 y "x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada, esto es por que esto es "x" a la 1 verdad y al
multiplicar sumamos los exponentes
de todos modos "x" por "x" ya sabes que es "x" cuadrada ¿Verdad? Así que esto es 8x cuadrada menos
5 por 2 es 10 por "x".
Nada mal vamos a hacer uno un poquito más complicado.
Digamos que tengo 9x al cubo por 3x cuadrada -2x más 7.
Así que otra vez vamos a utilizar la propiedad
distributiva. Aquí vamos a multiplicar el 9x al cubo por cada uno de los términos ¿Verdad? Así que
9x al cubo por 3x al cuadrado
dejen escribirlo, ya después lo haré a lo mejor como un cálculo mental
pero ahorita vamos a escribirlo entonces 9x al cubo por 3
"x" cuadrada y luego vamos a tener
más, o bueno déjenme ponerlo así -2x por 9x al cubo
y finalmente más 7 por 9x al cubo.
Así que algunas veces escribí 9x al cubo por el otro, a veces el otro por 9x al cubo en realidad no hace
diferencia ¿Verdad? Porque el orden de los factores no altera el producto,
así que el primer término que será 9 por 3
son 27 y "x" al cubo por "x" cuadrada se suman los exponentes y tenemos 2 más 2 son 5
menos 2 por 9 que son 18 y ahora "x" por "x" al cubo es
1 más 3 como sumo los exponentes y me da "x" a la 4 más 7 por 9 son 63
"x" al cubo así que terminamos con este lindo
polinomio de quinto grado.
Ahora vamos a hacer uno donde involucremos la multiplicación de dos
binomios y voy a mostrarles esto en unos segundos.
Esto es algo que verán muy frecuentemente en álgebra así que digamos que tengo "x" menos 3 por
"x" más 2 y de hecho quiero y quiero
mostrarles qué es lo que aquí realmente utilizamos, la propiedad distributiva varias veces ,así que déjen escribirlo
con verde del lado derecho.
Así que vamos a, vamos a pretender que este número que estoy enmarcando
esto en realidad es sólo un número ¿Verdad? Así que utilizando la propiedad distributiva sería este número
"x" menos 3 y multiplica a cada una de las variables del siguiente polinomio en este caso sería por "x" más
este número que es "x" -3 por 2.
Multiplicar por 2 este verde, ahora todo lo que hicimos fue distribuir este "x" más 2 con el factor "x"-3  pero
bueno vamos a recordar en general que si yo tengo a por "x" más 2
esto simplemente va a ser
déjenme ponerlo con los colores apropiados, esto es "a" por
"x" más "a"
por el número 2 ¿Verdad?
Así que aquí justamente nuestra "a" vale "x" -3 y fue justo lo que hicimos en este paso. Ahora volvemos a usar la propiedad
distributiva. En este caso vamos a distribuir "x" con "x" - 3 y el 2 con "x" -3.
Así que puedes ver qué es lo que va a ir saliendo ¿Verdad? Entonces en este caso déjenme
déjenme poner los colores como como van, aquí va "x" por "x"
-3 por
"x" más otra vez propiedad distributiva "x" por el 2
¿Ok? Esto ya está un poquito latoso pero  es -3 por
2 muy bien. Simplemente lo que utilizamos fue la propiedad distributiva aquí y
bueno quizás después lo hagas en un solo paso. Aquí estamos multiplicando
término por por término para que quede más claro pero, por que lo que realmente quiero es que quede clara la idea. Así que
"x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada, aquí tenemos -3x
aquí tenemos más 2x y aquí tenemos
- 6
¿Verdad? Ahora esto es "x" cuadrada y -3x más 2x simplemente es
-"x"-6
simplemente sumamos esos últimos, bueno los dos de en medio ¿Verdad?
Entonces simplemente ya con este ejemplo, ya no tengo que hacer todos estos pasos. Ya vimos claramente
cómo utilizar la propiedad distributiva. La forma fácil o la forma rápida de hacerlo es si tienes "x" -3 por  "x" más 2.
Literalmente multiplicas cada término por entre todos, así que
aquí por ejemplo es "x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada luego "x" por 2 es 2x luego -3 por "x" es
-3x  y -3 por 2
es m- 6 ¿Verdad? Y que es justamente ya simplificando es "x" cuadrada -"x" - 6.
Entonces como viste bueno toma un poquito de práctica para tomar este
para poder hacerlo de esta forma pero, bueno esto nos ahorra un poco en tiempo ¿Verdad?
Ahora vamos a multiplicar un binomio por un trinomio
¿Ok?
Quizás mucha gente para
asustarlos pero, aquí no, aquí somos valientes.
Digamos que tengo el 3x más 2 por 9x cuadrada -6x más 4.
Ahora podrías hacerlo exactamente como lo hicimos en esta última parte,
tomamos 3x más 2 y vas multiplicando a cada uno de los términos y después vas a distribuir
cada uno de los términos por 3x más 2 ¿Verdad? Pero bueno vamos a obtener la misma respuesta.
Cuando cuando tienes polinomios más grandes, la forma más fácil de pensar cómo multiplicarlos es simplemente,
vamos a escribirlo de esta forma. Por ejemplo 9x cuadrada -6x más 4
y vamos a multiplicar 3x más 2 ¿Ok? Es más o menos como cuando multiplicamos números.
¿Ok? Es más o menos lo mismo.
Tomamos un lugar para las
centenas, luego para las descenas y luego para las unidades. Aquí vamos a tomar lugares para las "x" cuadradas para las "x"
normales o para los
números sin "x" digamos, así que vamos a empezar aquí.
Vamos a hacer como una multiplicación tradicional 2 por 4 es 8 luego,
aquí vamos a dejar la columna de las constantes. Ahora multiplicamos a 2 por -6x
¿Ok? 2 por -6x eso es -12x, aquí ponemos -12 x
y entonces vamos a ponerle el má al 8 ¿Verdad? Y luego 2 por 9x cuadrada esto simplemente es 18 x cuadrado.
Ahora vamos a hacer la parte con 3x.
Vamos a ver cómo esto es diferente por que 3x por 4
3x por 4 es 12x
y lo ponemos en la columna donde están solo las "x". Ahora 3x por -6x esto simplemente es
3 por 6 es menos 18
bueno aquí es aquí es x cuadrado verdad x x x y luego 3 x menos 6 es -18
muy bien. Ahora
3x por 9x cuadrada simplemente es "x" por "x" cuadrada es "x" al cubo y 3 por 9 es 27.
Solo lo escribí en una columna aparte que es la correspondiente a las "x" cúbicas y ahora sumamos, esto es 8
aquí -12x más 12x se cancelan, y 18 -18 x cuadrada se cancelan ¿Verdad? Y simplemente nos queda
27x al cubo. Así que esto es igual a 27x al cubo más
8 y ya hemos acabado. Así que puedes utilizar esta técnica para multiplicar binomios, trinomios,
polinomios muy grandes. No importa quizás de grado 5 esto siempre va a funcionar, siempre y cuando tengas todo bajo su propia columna